So, the first part of our optimization tutorial is going to talk about optimization philosophy
because there are some things that you need to keep in mind when optimizing any Unreal
Engine project.
The first thing is that optimization isn't a stage in your project.
It is something that is started at the beginning of your project and then carried
out through the lifetime of your project.
Optimization should also be something that you do post-project for DLCs or any bug fixes
or things like that that you might need to apply to your project.
Now when you are working with optimization, you need to communicate budgets with your
team and there's also going to be no single magic setting or switch that will instantly
improve performance.
Real performance gains are going to come from small updates and refinements that all
work together to give you steady performance.
Performance should also be treated like a feature and not an afterthought.
That means that during prototyping, development, and polish, performance should be thought
about just like any other production-ready feature.
Performance is also everybody's responsibility.
You should be testing performance early on, you should be testing it often and consistently
and also always on your target platforms.
Again, remember, there shouldn't just be a stage where, okay, now we're going to get
to optimization and performance.
This is something that needs to be done through the lifetime of your project.
One of the other things that can help is defining good performance goals, but this
has a caveat of many times those require you asking questions like, how many triangles
or meshes can exist on screen at one time?
And the problem with that is that those numbers don't necessarily transfer from project
to project.
What worked on one project might not necessarily be the best for what works on another project.
A better way is to build the scene so that it looks like you want and then look for
opportunities to optimize.
Avoid setting strict limits such as there can only be 10 characters on screen at one
time and instead figure out ways to get past these with clever optimization and content
reduction in other areas so that you can have what you want without sacrificing performance
in other areas.
A couple of general best practices with performance just to keep in mind is that build
in a way that avoids common performance issues such as unnecessary math on each frame, keeping
texture sizes within reasonable limits and reduce the number of shading bends when possible,
and use instancing to improve rendering efficiency.
When we are trying to optimize builds based on profiling, we want to make sure that we
focus on improvements that are identified through profiling data.
We also want to try and avoid blindly optimizing things.
For example, if we know that materials can be an issue, but we don't know if they're
an issue on our project, don't go in and start optimizing all of your materials.
Make sure that you're using the profiling tools to determine if materials are an issue
or not and then go from there.
Remember, use the CPU and GPU profiling tools to identify specific bottlenecks and then
focus on those bottlenecks instead of making wild performance changes in areas that might
not necessarily benefit from doing performance work.
And finally, just to reiterate, remember that optimization and performance is something
that needs to be done throughout the lifetime of your project.
From the project start to the project end, everyone should be responsible for and always
looking at and trying to maintain the performance of any Unreal Engine 5 project they're working
on.